How do you know if it's a good idea to do a Syrex test?
So if you haven't dug into any of the sites that talk about Syrex testing, any other, I don't know what course, I talk about it a lot of the live course, I talk about it in the detox course that I'm going to go into in big detail on the autoimmune course that's coming out in January or February, because Syrex testing is very specific and anybody testing.
So Syrex is the name of a lab and they currently have about 15 different arrays as you can test them.
Their most common one is the antibody testing for food antibodies. So for food sensitivities, it is the most specific comprehensive test available.
In fact, I wouldn't even trust any of the other lab tests that are out there for food sensitivities, I would only do the Syrex.
It's also really good for if you're thinking that you have an autoimmune disease.
If you have a lot of people that are suspected, they have live disease again, and that they have a lot of neuronal issues like brain function issues and such to do what's called the Syrex 7x array 7x is very valuable because the test for neuronal antibodies, do you have antibodies to any brain tissue.
You're really helpful and in your treatment parameters, it's super helpful because if you have antibodies to neuronal tissue, there's very specific things that you have to really be careful with.
So I actually in the autoimmune course are going to have videos on all of these arrays, so it's going to be extensive.
So what is it a good idea to do a Syrex test if you suspect the autoimmune disease, if you suspect food sensitivities of any kind, that's where you do a Syrex test.